c'est un lieu clos de la la
contamination à la plus importante est
pas dehors
en lieu clos il faut vraiment porter le
masque
[Musique]
ça c'est le type de mesures empirique se
reposent sur rien en fait
scientifiquement et qui partait du
principe que quand vous aviez des gens
qui sont atteints qui tous est ce que
quelqu un n y revenir et bien comme vous
tous et vous pouvez avoir des postillons
qui partent à admettre
maintenant on n'en est plus là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est très bien dire qu'on va commander
64 pays en tête mais quand on voit en
pratique ce n'est prévu par blanc coeur
c'est quand même très très limité le
nombre de tests qui vont faire 300 mille
six cent mille et on veut que ça marche
il faudrait en gros chaque hélas pas
testé j'ai chaque semaine
[Musique]
la 3 édition israël de miley sur
l'angleterre un mois et demi par rapport
aux états unis ce qui signifie que
l'immunité collective qui valent qui
normalement doit profiter à tout le
monde y compris aux jeunes n'arrivera
pas avant la fin août en france
[Musique]